My guest this week
is the Pulitzer Prize winning
American photographer, Lynsey Addario.
Ukraine, Afghanistan, South
Sudan to name but a few,
she has been there with her camera
at the majority of the
conflicts in the 21st century.
I want to hear about the
stories behind those images
and what it's like living, working,
existing on the front lines of these wars.
Lynsey, thank you so much for joining me
and joining all of our viewers.
I know it's rare for you
to be sitting in a seat safely,
away from what you are covering
normally with your camera.
You've come to the world's
attention many times
with your work over the years.
But very recently, at the
beginning of this year,
in fact, just a few weeks after
the war started in Ukraine,
you did come to the
attention of many people
because you took a photo
of a Ukrainian family
of four trying to cross a
bridge who had been killed.
And that photo ended up
on the front pages of the New York Times.
Can you tell me a bit about
how you came to that seat?
So, I went and I went directly to the east
and was covering the
east for about 10 days
before the war started.
When the war began, I went to Kiev.
And immediately, was covering sort of,
daily missile strikes and the destruction
and those who had been killed and injured.
And so one day I was
watching images come out
from the wires and others
who went to the Irpin Bridge.
And there were, you know,
hundreds of civilians crossing,
the elderly women children
crossing out of Irpin
in all of those suburbs.
And so, we made our way toward the bridge
through side roads.
And as we approached there were injured,
the territorial defense
soldiers were taking injured
over to sort of a brick
wall off to the side.
So, we ran across the street.
And almost as soon as
we got behind that wall
a round came in.
So, it was either a mortar
round or a tank shell.
We're not sure.
It came in and hit sort
of off to the distance.
And then, the Ukrainian
military fired back.
And so, my security advisor
said, "Would you like to go?"
And I said, "No, because everyone knows
this is a civilian evacuation route.
And those rounds are probably going
toward a Ukrainian base
that's off in the distance."
But how wrong I was.
The next round came in closer.
And so, we dove for cover and
as soon as we pop back up,
the next round came in right
next to us essentially.
And it was sort of equidistant between us
and a mother and her two
children and a church volunteer
that was helping usher them to safety.
It was very chaotic.
And obviously, we were
all sort of in shock
because the round had
landed very close to us.
Everything was very dusty.
And our security advisor
immediately went to the
aid of, of the injured
and to a soldier who was nearby.
And by the time he
called us over, you know,
the protocol is, we wait
to be told, you know.
It's clear. You can come.
And so, by the time he called us over,
I ran across the street
not knowing what to expect.
Obviously, I knew there
was someone injured,
but I anticipated it being a soldier.
And although there were
civilians crossing steadily
and even during the strike, I mean,
because nothing was shielded.
So people had to continue to move.
And so when I got there,
I came upon these four lifeless bodies.
Of course, I didn't know if they were dead
or alive at that point.
I noticed sort of the tiny
little moon boots of a child.
And as a mother, that was sort of,
incredibly jarring and devastating moment.
And I was trying to survey but
I was also kind of in shock.
One side of my brain was sort of saying,
you have to start photographing
and you have to take these pictures
because I knew that I had
just witnessed a, you know,
something that was an intentional
targeting of civilians.
And so, I took a few photographs.
But rounds were still coming in.
Our security advisor,
Steve was saying, you know,
"Hurry up, work very quickly
and we have to leave."
And so, I kind of moved around the scene
and taking a few photographs,
thinking in my head also,
I have to be respectful.
And, you know, perhaps I
shouldn't show the faces.
So I was trying to take pictures
that showed the faces and
that didn't show the faces
so that we had some options.
Well, the image that I'm talking about,
or certainly the version I've seen,
you don't necessarily look at
the faces actually the way,
now you've said that, the way
that you look at the image.
You can.
You can see them.
But it's more you look
at the scene of a family.
Exactly.
I've been covering war for over 20 years,
and I know that there are
so many images I've taken
that have never been published
because they're graphic.
And so I was thinking of
that as I was shooting,
as horrible as that sounds
because obviously I've just witnessed
the most devastating scene.
But I'm also a photojournalist
and that's my job.
And so, I was trying different angles.
And frankly, I didn't think the picture
could ever be published
because it was civilians.
Do you know the impacts of that photo?
Yeah.
I mean, it's been used by I think,
the United States Ambassador
to the United Nations
to talk about the intentional
targeting of civilians.
It's been used repeatedly as proof
that civilians were targeted because,
I was there, I witnessed the run up.
And I know that whoever
was firing those rounds
was bracketing onto that position.
You mentioned being a mother.
Has that changed the job for you?
Yeah.
I mean, it's definitely changed the job
in the sense that I'm more cautious now
than I was before I had children.
I think to a sort of normal person
who doesn't do this for a living,
they probably can't see that.
But for me, making decisions
on a minute to minute basis
in a war zone, I know
I'm being more cautious.
I know I'm not going sort of,
all the way to the front or as far forward
as some of my colleagues might be going.
You also are now seeing,
perhaps when you see an image
where you create an image,
when you see the reality of a child
who is dead in front of you
would've always affected you, I imagine.
Always.
Has it changed though?
Yes, it has changed.
I think, you know, I photographed,
I have photographed children
dying in Iraq, in Afghanistan,
in Somalia during the Horn
of Africa drought in 2011.
And it was always devastating.
But I think now as a mother,
the first thing I do is sort of put myself
in the shoes of that mother.
And I know, you know,
I live in constant fear
that something will happen to my children.
So you're trying to keep yourself safe,
but you are also trying to
document at the same time.
Of course.
And perhaps processing it
in a slightly different way.
I mean, would you say you have
become desensitized though?
No.
Or do you have to be in any way?
No. Not at all.
I mean, I think I have ways of dealing
with my emotion in that moment.
But, you know, part of that
is just really focusing
on the task at hand, which
is making photographs
and looking through the view finder.
That definitely helps me
focus on taking pictures.
But I'm not desensitized at all.
I mean, I cry pretty much all the time
when I'm photographing.
I get very, very
emotional. And that's okay.
I mean, I don't have an issue with that.
I don't know what my
colleagues think of me,
but, you know, I think it's normal.
I mean, I'm a human being.
I mean, you talked about hanging back
because of the risk as well,
not necessarily going
straight to the front.
And yet, when I asked you
about that particular image,
it sounded like it's very instinctive
when you know you're
not where you need to be
and you are heading towards danger.
Correct.
And that's obviously what I struggle with
because if I'm close and something happens
a little closer or a
little further from me,
but closer to the
frontline, I'll likely go.
But I think, where I'm
positioning myself is sort of,
a little removed back
and then making judgment
calls every day, you know.
If I hear that a school has been hit
and 30 children have been
killed, I will go, you know.
If I hear that a building has
been hit on the frontline,
but no civilians were
killed, I'm likely not to go.
So, I'm weighing sort of,
what will I gain from risking my life.
Although that building's been hit,
but no civilians have been killed.
I mean, this talks to the
idea of, not you per se,
but a criticism of those in
your field of being war junkies,
trying to find the very worst to document.
And being in places they don't need to be,
sometimes causing perhaps more risk.
What do you say to that?
You know, for me, the highest toll of war
is civilian casualties.
So that's not being a war junkie,
that is documenting reality.
And the reality is, we are in a situation
where one country has invaded another.
And every civilian who dies is
on account of that invasion.
And so I think that if I'm in a position
and civilians are being killed,
I have to document that.
That is a very important part of the job
of someone who covers conflict.
And presumably, for you
in this work that you do,
you don't obviously just cover war.
You covered humanitarian
disasters, climate change,
the effects on the planet on that
but when it is about civilians,
it sounds like the justification
you have to make to
yourself, to your family,
and to those who could be critical,
is that you are providing evidence.
Yeah.
And that evidence has been used already
by the United Nations.
Have you taken pictures
of people killing others of
the actual killers before?
I mean, I've taken pictures of people
who have been accused of killing others,
but I have not been there
sort of, in the moment.
I just wonder what that's
like as well, you know,
seeing people do the very worst
they can do to each other.
I think people
are very smart about
journalists, you know.
They obviously don't
allow us access to things
when they're killing civilians, you know.
I think that there was a
time in the Korengal Valley,
I was with the American
troops, the 173rd Airborne.
I had spent two months living
on the side of a mountain with the 173rd.
Me and a colleague, Elizabeth Rubin,
for the New York Times Magazine.
And the point was to
understand the nuances of war
and why so many civilians
were dying in Afghanistan.
And in fact, Lieutenant Colonel Olson,
who was the commander of the
Korengal Valley, was very smart
because he had this
philosophy of transparency
because he believed
that journalists needed
to understand sort of the nuances of war
to understand why civilians
were being killed.
And so, we were in Rock Avalanche,
which was in the movie,
the documentary "Restrepo"
that, I don't know if you've seen it,
but it's extraordinary.
And so, we were in that operation
where we jumped out of helicopters
in the middle of the night
into the heart of Taliban territory,
literally walked with everything
we owned for six days.
And eventually we were
ambushed by the Taliban.
And we were ambushed from three sides.
And there was a huge gun battle.
Three soldiers were shot, one was killed.
And in the retaliation
of the American troops,
I was standing with some of the soldiers.
Everyone was very shaken up, of course.
And one of the soldiers said,
"Look, they're using Afghan women
and children as human shields."
And he literally had me look
through the scope of his gun.
And there were women and children
on the roofs of the building
where they were shooting from.
And that is a case where it
was incredible to witness.
And I could only have witnessed that
because I had spent so much
time with these troops.
And really, was willing to risk my life
and to be there in the middle
of Operation Rock Avalanche.
A shot you took during that maneuver.
We're gonna take a look at that.
Can you take me through it?
There is an image,
the aftermath of that ambush,
where it's a very dusty picture.
It is a scout team carrying
the body of Sergeant Rougle.
And he's in a body bag.
And it was after that.
And the scout team, Clonard
who is sort of leading the way, is crying.
And they're walking through
this very sort of desolate landscape.
And I remember shooting that
photograph and asking myself,
what are we doing here, you know.
What are we doing here years after 9/11?
Fighting in the middle of the mountains
where there are no people, you know?
And it just felt like such a waste
that this young man had died for nothing.
And in fact, a few years later,
the American troops pulled
out entirely from that area.
There's another image of yours
I wanted to bring to mind
and for us to have a look at
and talk about an 18 year old woman
in labor, stranded in 2009.
Tell me about that and
how that came about.
So in 2009,
I won a MacArthur Fellowship
that is in America.
It's called the Genius Grant.
And it's essentially given
to all different disciplines,
from a cellist to a scientist,
to a photographer where I was
paid a salary for five years
with no strings attached
to just focus on my work.
And I felt a lot of pressure to decide
what to focus on with my work
because it was the first
time I could decide
not be assigned a story.
And so, I started doing research.
And I decided to focus
on maternal mortality
and why over 500,000 women a year
were dying in childbirth at that point.
This was 2009, as you said.
And Afghanistan,
where I had been working
for a decade at that point,
had one of the highest rates
of maternal death in the world.
And that was because there
was such a bad road network.
Women who were pregnant or in labor
didn't have access necessarily
to medical professionals
or to clinics, or hospitals
that were staffed with doctors.
They just couldn't get
where they needed to get?
to where they needed to.
They had to take a donkey for 12 hours.
And imagine being in labor, you know,
getting on the back of a donkey.
And so, I went to very remote villages
in Badakhshan Province,
which was one of these
provinces with high numbers.
And on the way back, I
was riding with Dr. Zeba,
who was also helping me translate.
And we noticed these two women
on the side of a mountain.
And there was not a man with them,
which in Afghanistan is very rare.
And we stopped the car and
said, "What are you doing here?
Do you need help?"
And it turned out the woman on the right,
Noor Nisa was in labor.
And Noor Nisa's husband's first
wife had died in childbirth.
And he was so determined to not lose her
that he managed to get
a car in the village.
But when we met them,
their car had broken down,
so they were stranded
on the side of the road.
So I said, "We'll, just get in my car.
I'll take you to the hospital.
We're going toward Fayzabad,
which was the capital of the state.
And they said, "No, we need
permission from the husband.
So, we'll wait.
And so, I turned to Dr. Zeba and I said,
"Okay, you have to find the husband.
There's one road in the whole province.
He's obviously on that road," you know?
So she found him, of
course, pretty quickly
and brought him back.
And the whole family piled in my car
and we took them to the hospital.
And everyone asked me
if she delivered safely
and if I took photographs.
And yes, she delivered safely.
But no, I did not take photographs
because I felt like I changed the course
of that story with my
presence by taking them.
But you took a photo?
I took about three frames,
and that photograph is
one of those frames.
And that's when you had
met and just seen it?
Cause it's so strikingly the blue.
Exactly. I met them.
We asked their story.
And then, we asked permission
right before Zeba left
to find the husband,
we asked permission for me
to take a few photographs.
Do you think on balance,
being a woman has been a
help to you in this field?
A huge help.
Rather than a hindrance?
Yes.
Everyone thinks it's a hindrance,
but in fact, it's a huge
help because people -
First of all, I have
access to men and women.
And particularly when I'm working
in countries like Afghanistan and Somalia,
where men and women are
usually segregated by gender.
And people underestimate women
I find, and they still do.
And so they sort of discount me and say,
Okay, sure, sure. Go do -
It's nice to be underestimated, isn't it?
Yeah I love being underestimated.
Over-deliver.
I love it.
Yeah.
It's one of those things.
But I mean, I suppose
on the other serious,
much more serious side
of it is that, again,
when you are thinking and
calculating risks, you know,
rape as a weapon of war,
is a unique tool wielded against women.
Yes. And for me, I've
been kidnapped twice.
The first time was in Iraq,
and that was only a day.
And it turned out, compared to Libya,
was quite sort of, it was manageable
in the sense that we were
working outside of Falluja.
I was working with a colleague
from the New York Times.
We had heard a helicopter of
American troops went down.
We went to find it.
We got caught by insurgents who thought,
maybe we were with the
American occupation.
We finally convinced
him we were journalists.
They held us until dusk, and
then eventually let us go.
Obviously, it was terrifying.
We had guns to our heads
for about 11 hours.
We didn't know if we would survive.
Libya was much more
violent, much more dramatic.
We were four journalists in one car.
Originally, we had been two in each car,
but one of the driver's brothers
had been shot at the front line.
So he quit in the middle of the battle
and we ended up in one car.
We had to decide how long to stay.
That is not an easy discussion,
because with four journalists,
everyone has a different
perspective on how long to stay,
what our needs are, how
dangerous the situation is.
By the time we decided to pull
back east toward Benghazi,
we ran into one of Gaddafi's
troop's check checkpoints.
It was incredibly hostile.
The rebels we had been covering
started opening fire on that checkpoint.
So we were literally in a wall of bullets.
The men were pulled out of the car.
Me as the only woman, I was
sort of left sitting there
because they didn't
know what to do with me.
But the car was not armored.
So I had to get out of the car
because I knew that I
needed to get behind cover.
I crawled across the backseat.
And when I jumped out, one
of Gaddafi's troops sort of,
came to me and was pulling at my cameras.
Instinctively, I was pulling back,
even though there were bullets,
literally going zoom zoom, you
know, next to, all around us.
We finally made it to cover
behind the sort of, checkpoint building.
And we're all told to lie
face down in the dirt.
We each had a kalashnikov
put to our heads,
and we were about to be executed.
We were begging for our lives.
The commander came over
at that point and said,
"You can't execute
them. They're American."
Which this was all in Arabic.
And Anthony Shadid
later translated for us.
You know, in retrospect,
I have no idea why they
spared us being American,
because in the Middle East,
a lot of people don't
like our foreign policy.
And so, we were tied up and blindfolded,
and essentially for the next
three days, we were beaten up,
tied up, blindfolded,
threatened with execution.
And for me, as the only woman,
I was touched repeatedly.
I was not raped.
But of course, in that time,
being tied up and blindfolded,
I thought of the many, many women
I have interviewed over the
years who have been raped.
And so I sort of ironically
looked to them for strength
because I thought, well,
if they survived it,
and if it happens to me,
I can survive it as well.
Are are you living just minute to minute?
Minute to minute.
Yeah. I mean in a kidnapping,
there is no sort of an hour down the line.
It is literally every
second is survival mode.
It is, what can I do to
get through this fear?
What can I do to get through this pain?
I mean, it sounds like
the scene from a film,
and yet it's your life.
And I believe Jennifer Lawrence
has been interested in
your life or there was
She was.
talk of a film?
We spent about three years together
when Warner Brothers optioned
the rights to my memoir.
I wrote a memoir after that called,
"It's What I Do, A Photographer's
Life of Love and War."
And that memoir was optioned
almost immediately by Warner Brothers.
Steven Spielberg was slated to direct,
and Jennifer Lawrence
was slated to play me.
And that went on for
three years if not longer.
What's it like
taking Jennifer Lawrence to war zones?
I took her to the border
with South Sudan when
it was very, very tense.
She wanted to understand
what it feels like
to feel that fear and to be, you know,
to be close to a war zone.
Obviously, we had to
worry about her safety,
so I couldn't take her.
You got an extra headache.
You gotta worry about Hollywood A lister
while you dealing with everything else.
It was very stressful let's just say,
when I put her on the plane
to, you know, from Uganda.
I couldn't walk for a week.
My back went out.
But she eventually dropped out.
And so now it is being
made into a limited series.
Okay.
So a TV series?
A TV series. Correct.
Okay.
But at least Jennifer Lawrence
now knows what it's like to do your job.
She does.
She's just come out with a movie
playing a character named Lynsey.
I hope I helped!
Can't think where she got
that inspiration from.
But what have you learned then,
from being in these scenarios,
coming in and coming out
of some of the worst things
we can do to each other?
Yeah.
I mean, I guess I've learned
the capacity for survival,
for resilience, for forgiveness.
The fact that human beings
can be equally evil as they
can be amazingly generous
and yeah, resilient.
I think that I've learned a lot
from the people I've covered.
But I think we have to look
at the ability of human beings
to live both within those situations
and to survive them after.
Well, thank you very much
for taking us behind the lens with you.
Thank you.
Lynsey.
And thank you so much for being with us.
Until we meet again,
take care and goodbye.